[Musik]
ich habe meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ich sage mal herzlich willkommen
und danke für ihr interesse
das heute hier sind im landhaus hier in
graz in der steiermark in meiner heimat
und ich glaube ich kann sagen zu einem
historischen tag nämlich zu einem
treffen der verteidigungsminister der
westbalkan staaten die sich zum letzten
mal in dieser form 2011 getroffen haben
und wir heute hier die möglichkeit haben
über sicherheitsrelevante themen in
einer guten atmosphäre in der wohnung
seiner steiermark sprechen zu können
ich möchte nochmals festhalten unsere
aufgabe als ratspräsidentschaft ist das
zum einen brücken zu bauen aber auch
ganz klare signale auszusenden und zu
sagen wir müssen sicherheit exportieren
um nicht um sicherheit nach österreich
kommt nach europa zu importieren
aber wir arbeiten auch an einem
strategischen format das bedeutet dass
die europäische union auch mit den
ländern des westbalkans noch mehr auch
in kontakt treten kann
nach dem motor nicht über sie sprechen
sondern mit ihnen zu sprechen
[Musik]